you're more than they can ever be
they're just foot soldiers in the Great
War you will make Kings rise and fall
your which you're going to hurt him
I see a darkness in you
and in that darkness eyes staring back
at me brown eyes blue eyes green eyes
eyes you'll shut forever
we will meet again
hey youtubers is Charlie so little birds
have spotted a very particular someone
near the set of Game of Thrones implying
that Arya is going to have a reunion if
not a couple reunions during the season
so this is going to be a breakdown just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened so far so the big news
is that just like a random Game of
Thrones fan spotted Joe Dempsey at the
Belfast Airport arriving so everyone's
like oh man oh man they're filming Game
of Thrones right now that means they
Gendry is coming back it doesn't
necessarily guarantee that he's going to
appear during season 7 but pretty much
all the Game of Thrones actors that
showed up in belfast around this time
last year ended up appearing during the
season like a lot of them tried to pass
it off as like oh the you know they're
just visiting the people on the set
they're just having some fun nope they
all appeared like Rory McCann BAM he was
in Game of Thrones Season six OSHA and
Rickon BAM Game of Thrones Season six so
I'd say it's a safe bet that they're
gonna circle back around and touch on
what kendrys been doing this whole time
just think about how big his arms are
for rowing for that many seasons so just
a reminder about where he's been and
what's been going on in the books that
they've already skipped over on the TV
show because there is Gendry stuff that
happens in the books it's relatively
minor but they combined him with heed
Rick's storm character on the TV show so
for the time he was on screen in the
first three seasons he actually got way
more story all the stuff that happened
to Dragonstone at the end of season 3
that was the heed Rick Storm stuff that
they gave him from the books so sir
Davos said sim-free and is just like get
the hell out of here go back to King's
Landing hide out in flea bottom live a
very quiet mundane life and be happy
about it so again re Rose off never to
be seen again so in the books up to that
point would it happen with the Gendry
character is that he just stayed at the
crossroads so if you remember he went
with MELAS like Melisandre took him well
in the books he just continued to be the
blacksmith at the Inn at the crossroads
so the TV show blew that wide open
we never got Lady Stoneheart The Hound
was reunited with the Brotherhood and
rejoined them as they headed north
Arya came back to Westeros and went to
the twins to take care of some Freight
pies so as George our Martin has already
answered fans question
about Aria Gendry stuff they're like are
they ever gonna meet up again in the
books and he's like yeah of course
they're gonna meet up again he didn't
say how they're gonna meet up again but
keep in mind that what they might do as
they have would say like the Jamie's
story line when they circled back around
in season six to do the river run
Jamie's stuff is they might circle back
around to do Gendry Brotherhood stuff
so remember when Gendry and Aria were
last together she was really upset
because she wanted them to stay together
but he was like I belong here I have a
purpose I'm a good blacksmith they need
a blacksmith they're doing good things I
mean kind of good things scanner II was
kind of willfully ignorant about some of
the more terrible things that the
Brotherhood was doing so gondry on the
TV show might slowly try to rejoin the
Brotherhood but we don't know exactly
where they are they're still in the
Riverlands somewhere but they're
travelling north so there's going to be
at least a little bit of Riverrun stuff
next year but there is a question as to
where aria is going to go so you have
Ari at Riverrun
you have the Hound in the Brotherhood
that were last seen near the salt pans
kind of where they were in the books and
then you have the end of the crossroads
potentially where Gendry might be so you
have like a bunch of reunions arya
seeing the Hound again in Aria seeing
Gendry again so let me know in the
comments do you think that they're going
to keep the arias stuff down in the
Riverlands and she will meet up with the
Hound in Gendry during the season or do
you think separately they'll all start
to travel north and they'll converge and
have like their big reunion moment near
Winterfell
because Arya did say that she was going
home she is Arya Stark of Winterfell so
it sounds like she will make her way
back to Winterfell eventually if not
really soon so just remember that
there's seven episodes but because Arya
is a main character we'll probably get
more scenes with her than we would
separately just with the Hound or just
with Gendry that if they converge and
they meet with Arya then you'll see a
whole lot more of them just because of
their proximity to her and that says
nothing about how crazy it's gonna be
because Arya has been thinking about
these people for a long time she hasn't
really mentioned Gendry that much she
mentioned the Hound when she was playing
the game of faces but he had the idea of
her seeing these two people that she
really cared about like the people that
she had kind of made her family I don't
know that she would call the Hound her
family Kendra was
like the last person who she was like
actively trying to make part of her
family like I would be your lady I don't
think that she even knows that Gendry is
secretly Robert Sun the hound might know
but I don't think that she really cares
about that like they probably wouldn't
be talking about that but Gendry is kind
of in the same spot with John snow when
it comes to being a bastard and feeling
like an outsider so I think the Aria
doesn't care about any of that stuff so
it's gonna be really fun seeing how she
deals with that like you don't really
see her crying here she seems so
hardcore but I feel like the sight of
Gendry would just like immediately warp
her back to being like a 10 year old
girl and she would just break down
crying like she wouldn't know what to do
like when Brienne is meeting with Jaime
and there's all these things between
them that they don't say like they just
exchange these looks and they both look
like they're going to explode from the
tension in the air so it's going to be a
lot of fun like there's a lot of really
touching moments during this you have
like your WTF big action set pieces like
the big battles you have the big ohmygod
moments like where Cersei blows up the
great set then you have more
heartwarming moments like when Santa
gave Jon Snow the cloak that looked just
like Ned Stark's like oh you know you
look like you've taken father's place
like this is so touching that you've
returned to Winterfell so you have some
moments like that with Arya like Ari has
just been WTF for the last couple of
episodes being chased around by the wave
then finally making the decision to come
home avenging her family's murder at the
red wedding with some freight pies so
she's due for a really heartwarming
touching moment so I feel like we'll see
some of that either with Gendry with the
Hound depending on when she runs into
them but there's a couple different ways
that could go down it just seems logical
that that would happen somewhere in the
Riverlands because each of those three
different groups of characters like
injury The Hound and the Brotherhood and
Arya are all still in that area of
Westeros so it makes sense that they
would converge somewhere maybe at
Riverrun maybe closer to the twins I'm
really hoping that Arya eventually tries
to cross Cersei off her list but they've
been hyping Cersei versus tener so much
it seems like Daenerys is going to try
and complete the task before Arya has
the chance so we'll just have to wait
and keep our eyes peeled on the set to
see who else shows up I'm really hoping
that young Ned Stark and Lyanna stark
show up again hypetrain totally on
schedule this year and also
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Kurtis Hinson you want
dollar Amazon giftcard be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details so what's going to happen next
is they just announced some Punisher
stuff for Punisher season 1 YouTube
itself like you know outside of like the
really cool stuff that I normally talk
about YouTube changed a bunch of
features so there are a few things that
look different the comments section may
look a little bit different so I might
make a video for that just explaining
like all the WTF YouTube changes there
were a couple nightmare things that
happened last night but it wasn't that
big a deal usually anytime there's like
a big problem on YouTube they fix it
really quickly
but there's just like a couple new
things that it might take a day or two
to get used to so be sure to subscribe
to get all that stuff should post by
later tonight while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn
all about the Ironborn during season 7
and you can click here to learn all
about the new Wolverine movie doing mr.
sinister and if you guys didn't notice
if you're watching this on your mobile
phone they change this so you can
actually click on these links now so
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you